welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and this is a breakdown of the
first episode of house of the dragon a
game of thrones prequel series adapted
from george rr martin's fire and blood i
actually started on this channel writing
all of and eventually hosting the game
of thrones analyses and look how young
and innocent that little boy walked he
had no idea what laid before him and how
a career in youtube would plague him
with social disorders but hey i'm still
excited to return to westeros not just
to list a random number of easter eggs
but really to dig into the deeper
thematic subtext analyze the interesting
cinematic details and make that hbo
flavored violence even sexier and that
hbo flavored sex even more violent
this episode opens with narration from
adult rainier a targaryen who will be
played by emma darcy in future episodes
she's recounting the great council of
101. the dynasty of aegon the conqueror
went aegon then aenese then maegor and
now jaehaerus jiharis's first son eamonn
had died nine years prior leaving behind
eamon's daughter rhaenys but she was the
queen who never was passed over for his
second son balon who had just died of a
burst appendix warring factions begin to
rally so jaharis gathered this council
to decide his heir and prevent civil war
but a difference from the book here it
did not come down to viserys and rhaenys
rhaenys made a claim but was immediately
discounted due to her being a woman it
really came down to viserys and
rhaenys's son leonor velaryon whom we
will meet later in this series but here
they emphasize rhaenys getting slighted
to connect this history to the similar
succession drama that goes down with
rhaenyra this setting is harrenhal you
remember that from season 2 of game of
thrones it's the largest structure in
westeros that was chosen to house these
1000 lords notice how the targaryen's
hair blows in the wind as this castle is
in a ruined state exposed to the
elements why because a century earlier
aegon's dragon balerion torched this
place to the ground really the fact that
viserys was the final targaryen prince
to ride valerion who had died seven
years before this was a major factor
that led to him being chosen as
jiharis's heir and now with his hair
blowing in his wind he really does fit
the bill of a dragon rider who torched
places just like this also a prince who
uses conditioner maybe he's born with it
or maybe he's got dragon dreams rainer's
voice over says in those days house
targaryen stood at the height of its
strength
with ten adult dragons under its yoke
under its yoke ah yeah right viserys
reveals that the targaryen's actual
control of the dragons is an illusion
also yolk yolk as in that of an egg an
egg does become a key symbol later this
episode the scroll that jaharis reads is
stamped with the sigil of the order of
maesters a ring of chains notice how the
masters of this series wear chains that
are more varied than the chains worn by
the maesters in the game of thrones
series really because each link is meant
to represent mastery of a completely
different field kind of like merit
badges though i don't know if these
majors really deserve one for ob gyning
the opening title shows the targaryen
sigil of the three dragon heads and
music from returning game of thrones
composer ramin jawadi
yeah you'll notice the end has that same
bass string trimmer
that jawadi would use in the house
targaryen theme in game of thrones right
before a dragon would dracarys
[Music]
and you'll notice we don't really get a
classic game of thrones style animated
game board opening however i do think we
get a nod to that game of thrones game
board hidden interestingly in this
episode later on then we jump ahead
about a decade later as ronira rides her
gold-colored dragon cyrax through the
clouds yes it took multiple seasons in
game of thrones to get to dragons but
this one starts right off with him a way
bigger budget's always a beautiful thing
notice on the red keep some construction
scaffolding is visible this castle was
completed decades earlier finished by
maegor the cruel who also ordered the
construction of the great dragon pit
which you can see in the background here
still beautiful and intact the ruins of
this dragon pit were seen in game of
thrones where in season seven daenerys
talked about how mocking the dragons in
this pit destroyed the targaryens this
place was the beginning of the end for
my family we weren't extraordinary
without them
we were just like everyone else a
reality that rhaenyra admits using the
same words at the end of this episode
without them it's like everyone else as
cyrex lands the elder dragon keeper uses
his staff to halt the younger one and
they speak in high valyrian commands
ohiris meaning i think to serve as in
valar dojaris but i think in this
context maybe it means obey then umbas
not really sure about that one maybe it
means inline rybas which means listen or
hear and then later nayot which means
forward ronira's friend is alison
hightower who says cyrax is growing
quickly should soon be as large as
correct sees
that's almost large enough to settle too
crazy's is demon's dragon nicknamed the
bloodworm for its extra long neck you'll
notice these dragons wear saddles which
makes sense for animals one would ride
daenerys never used a saddle to ride
drogon in game of thrones and when they
asked how daenerys could stay on this
dragon some people who worked on the
show told my colleague joanna robinson
over on the ringerverse podcast that
apparently it had to do with drogon
spikes in the way a hat sits on a hook i
know by the way it's important to be on
top of your mental health which is why
it's so frustrating when you can't find
a therapist if you think you might be
feeling depressed stressed anxious or
overwhelmed better help is here to help
this video is sponsored by better health
better help offers licensed therapists
who are trained to listen and help you
better help allows you to message your
therapist in a private online
environment at your convenience better
helps network has over 20 000 therapists
with a broad range of expertise and
specialties giving you access to help
that may not be available in your area
just fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and you'll be
matched to a therapist in under 48 hours
once you're matched you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions and
exchange unlimited messages everything
you share is completely confidential and
if you ever want to request a new
therapist you can at any time with no
additional charge over 3 million people
have taken charge of their mental health
with an experienced better health
therapist if you're interested in
proving your mental health with better
help you can get 10 off your first month
at betterhelp.com new rockstars or click
the link in the description that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-elp.com
new rockstars for 10 off your first
month but yes ronero does mention a
saddle for two in this episode does end
with a two-seated saddle just on a
different dragon karaxis as damon and
missouri elite but notice how we cut
back to cyrax here and realized that
only then did this dragon turn back into
the pit cyrax was watching these two
girls for their whole conversation as if
not trusting allison the carriage rolls
past the statue of valerian the black
dread remember that was aegon's dragon
last written by viserys several years
prior these girls stroll through the red
keep courtyard this looks like the same
location cersei lannister would later
convert to the map floor in the later
seasons of the game of thrones over all
of this joanie's main game of thrones
melody plays because you know hbo really
needs us to remember the good times and
queen emma's chamber instance burns and
a maester writes a desk this guy's
likely working on those moon charts that
mellows will later update the king about
a septa lights candles in front of wall
art that depicts several characters
apparently in an orgy this chamber is
covered in porny imagery maybe to
encourage fertility some nurseries have
like plush toys this one has hand job
art emma says this discomfort is how we
serve the realm i'd rather serve as a
knight and ride to bustling glory while
rhaenyra is presented as a daedris
figure here she echoes arya you
will marry a high lord and rule this
castle
no that's not me
emma then says the child bed is our
battlefield an important foreshadowing
line because later director miguel
sapochnick will intercut between the
bloody fight and attorney and the even
bloodier scenes of the childbirth
because whereas tourneys are pretend
wars that often end in the night
yielding emma didn't have that option
her child bed was a literal battlefield
where they tried to decide kings and
ultimately like many battlefields no one
really walked away from it on to the
king's small council
well i believe you might be looking up
the wrong end
[Laughter]
yes viserys finishes a dirty joke maybe
even the punchline to tyrion's never
ended joke from game of thrones i once
brought a jackass and a honeycomb into a
brothel silence what happened next but
if you look online there are actually
quite a few really great possible
answers to that one notice how vasaris
eats a boiled egg now a dragon egg will
become a major plot point with damon
later on this season but this episode
also draws a parallel to viserys's
unborn child and an egg after this
miserable pregnancy
i wouldn't be surprised if i hatched an
actual dragon now this is a cruel
parallel but viserys eats a boiled egg
here while his baby egg does not survive
and ends up getting cooked buzzer
viserys a small council includes his
hand otto hightower master of laws
lionel strong grand maester melos master
of coin lyman breesbury and master of
ships coreless velaryon lord of
driftmark his sigil the seahorse he's
husband rhaenys he and all the valerions
have silver hair because valerians are
really kissing cousins to the targaryens
both emma and vizera smelled dragon on
their daughter i love this detail
because it gives a new sensory weight to
creatures that otherwise would just come
off as vfx nothings but like any riding
animal dragons would have a scent to
them i'm gonna guess it's smoky otto
brushes off corliss's warnings about
craig as the craft beater and the step
stones and otto tries to redirect to a
lighter subject of the tourney but since
this tourney is in honor of viserys's
unborn son the subject is actually even
more serious because notice how cordless
refuses wine from rhaenyra so that he
can listen closely to the melos's
updates about the health and sex of that
child later in the episode you'll notice
after emma's death corliss pours wine
but is in surprise when otto brings up
the succession matter he's like
[ __ ] i want to be sober for this
stuff sir harold westerling takes
raniera to the throne room he passed
through the red keeps gates at
frostlight does my father know his head
no good
we just learned quite a bit about prince
demon his reputation preceding him damon
is a massive celebrity yet somehow he
managed to sneak into the red keep with
very few noticing master of sneaks this
tells us that damon has some pretty
tight connection with the city watch
that viserys has a blind spot for his
brother that rhaenyra likes having
secrets with her uncle and that damon
might know some hidden passageways
around the castle that others don't
maegor the cruel actually had the
builders of this castle killed to keep
its secrets but maybe damon has learned
some of them damon sits on the iron
throne got to be good notice how the
iron throne is a larger nest of swords
and it wasn't game of thrones it's now
closer to the description in george r.r
martin's text where it's supposed to be
more of a mound of swords but still to
connect it with its look at game of
thrones they essentially just added a
briar patch of swords surrounding the
throne but by designing this way you can
see how aegon recklessly just tossed
more and more swords into that pile and
just had valerion melt it with
dragonfire making this a bit of a
historical deconstruction to that grand
design of the targaryen dynasty uh-uh it
actually seems more like a hasty
scramble as this sloppy dynasty more
truly was george r martin's the rogue
prince said of damon in his day there
was not a man so admired so beloved and
so reviled in all of westeros he was
made of light and darkness and equal
parts to some he was a hero to others he
was the blackest of villains similarly
notice how it takes us a moment to see
damon in the light as this uncle and
niece speak in high valyrian
the throne and the surrounding swords
cast demon in shadow giving him a
deceitful look about him also notice how
he leans forward and to his right unlike
his brother who leans back and lanes on
the left armrest when he sits on the
throne damon seems to instinctively know
how to sit on this throne without
getting cut because their ancestor egg
on the conqueror designed it in such a
way with exposed still sharp swords that
would make it really uncomfortable to
sit in and make the iron throne not much
of a desirable seat to what damon gives
his niece a necklace it's valerian steel
like dark sister
dark sister is the name of daemon's
sword first carried by aegon's sister
visenya notice how as he yanks that
necklace back he grips it in fist like a
chain wrapped around knuckles as a kind
of weapon valerian steel is extremely
rare since the art of fortunate was lost
in the doom of valyria so to use it for
jewelry therefore just seems insane but
symbolically it links these two in a
kind of relationship or relationship
that will be a weapon wielded against
many others in this series rhaenyra and
allison sit in the godswood you can see
the red leaves of the weirwood tree and
its face with the bleeding eyes and the
white trunk behind them the wherewit
trees represent the old gods these were
carved by the children of the forest and
many of these were cut down by the first
men who believed that the children's
greenseers could use these trees faces
to spy on men and the fact that rhaenyra
and allison have this little
disagreement over the value of
rhaenyra's royal position in the
presence of a weirwood tree is
significant as if the old gods are
watching these two future queens begin
to square off as friends allison quizzes
rainier about princess nymeria the
namesake of arya's direwolf and the
warrior queen who led the rhino and
conquered dorne and took morris martel
as her husband turns out rhaenyra does
know this history but she tears the page
out of the book showing how she is
unbound by historical precedent but
ironically it is these kind of
historical textbooks that bring alison
in between renier and her father viserys
viserys is treated for a wound it's a
small cut from sitting the throne it's
nothing otto tells mello's to keep it
quiet because getting cut from the
swords of the iron throne is meant to be
a bad omen for a ruler as damon said
earlier you are all cursed with me and
notice this cut is on viserys's lower
left back the side that demon leaned
away from the iron throne when he sat on
it the maester attendant says it's a
wound that refuses to heal grand maester
the unhealable wound is a jungian
archetype in fiction a physical malady
representing a spiritual curse that a
character must bear for viserys this
unhealable wound is really a
manifestation of the curse of his
family's exploitation of dragon power
and the folly of their dreams which is
really the deeper theme of this episode
anna tells reservists that rhaenyra
declared the baby a
girl her
darian
vicinia
she chose the dragon's eye for the
cradle that she said reminded her of
vega that'd be good
this family already has it visenya huh
remember rhaenyra told others that she
wanted the baby to be a son for
viserys's sake so we learn here that
ranira actually lies depending on who
she is talking to now visenya was
aegon's sister wife carrier of dark
sister writer of the dragon vagar vagar
by the way still alive and it was
vicinia who produced maegor the cruel
both of these were really considered to
be the unstable branch of targaryens so
viserys here is saying we already had
one visinia in our history but also
visenya's spirit lives on in daemon but
zera said he dreamed that the baby was a
boy wearing aegon's iron crown i heard
the sound of her thundering moves
splintering shields and ringing swords
and i placed our son up on the early
throne
as the bells of the grand septal
and all the dragons roared as one dreams
are incredibly important to the
targaryens not just aegon's dream that
viserys reveals later the targaryens
first came to westeros from valyria
because of a dream danis the dreamer
dreamt that valyria would be destroyed
in an apocalyptic event and the people
of valyria mocked her in the family but
her father aynar believed her and the
family fled to dragonstone 12 years
after that dreams confirmed valeria was
destroyed in an earthquake and volcano
leaving the targaryen as really the only
dragon riders left in the world and the
targaryens walked away from that as a
family obsessed with dreams and prophecy
a curse that will poison every
generation of targaryens after this
damon unleashes a city guard on king's
landing these gold cloaks just
cherry-pick targets and butcher them
now we will have to censor this visually
but i'm pretty sure the guy they
castrate lets out a nervous fart when
they strip off his pants
i swear we did not edit the audio of
that damon's helmet is designed to look
like a dragon with its wings folded in
but this does not look like his dragon
karaxis which is red and has a long neck
rather this looks more like balerian the
black dread so with his armor damon is
really trying to cast himself as an
inevitable heir to aegon's dynasty the
small council meets again but this time
with daemon present still smeared in
blood they mark their presence with
balls on plates the set decorator and
production designer came up with these
as a way of punching in for work but i
like how this gives each member's play
setting and intentionality to it four
members to visseris's left cordless at
the far end furthest away having to
shout to be heard and then in the hand
of the king otto alone on viserys is
right his casual whispers most effective
now in the brothel with daemon in
missouri we start this scene with other
women peeping in at them through the
slots in the wall this indicates that
nothing damon does at these brothels is
private and for us it connects the
viewer with the boyers rather than with
the participants because that's what we
are we're we're privy little boys
missouri offers i could bring in another
we could even arrange one with silvera
yikes this tells us that damon has in
the past requested a partner who looks
like she's related to him so that moment
with reneera wasn't so pure was it as
vernier enters the king's booth of the
tourney nudist master of coin lime and
beesberry has a massive coin pouch in
his crotch obviously to place bets but
you know you know that's a bit of a
thirsty way of showing what's important
to alignment but interesting that
rhaenyra is late and noticeable poreless
signals with his hand right as she
sneaks behind rainies as if these two
might have some kind of connection now
in the opening joust sir kristen cole
clashes with the tarly knight all the
major houses are represented here you
see a baratheon stag the manderly eagle
the stark direwolf the bolton flayed man
the tully fish a squire dressed with
lannister lions on either side of the
royal booth notice are valerian
seahorses meaning cordless his entourage
has to sit outside the royal box poor
guy always get in bad seats damon
selects his opponent sir wayne hightower
of old town making a dig at otto of
house hightower this is his son worried
for her brother allison bites her thumb
and later we see her picking at it till
it bleeds an interesting motif with some
of these characters always having some
bloody fingers corliss and rhaenys comet
i wonder if this is how we should
celebrate the birth of our future king
with wanting violence it's been 70 years
since king maegor's end these nights
were as green as summer grass none have
known real war these violent delights
intercut with the true battlefield of
this episode emma's childbed melos tells
vazera that he must either sacrifice
emma to try to save the child or lose
them both the technique is taught at the
citadel which involves cutting directly
into the womb to free the infant ah to
free the child it's like saying the
wretched womb is trapping the child
medical
practice while emma's screams initially
bleed over into the shouts of the
tourney when we come back to her later
her screams are muted while all we hear
are the sounds of the fighting it's like
her whole identity is being muted and
cruelly snuffed out this brutal realism
contrasts with supnic's stylized shots
of the joust using the dividing pole as
a camera track line to follow damon long
as his bat grinds along against it i
also appreciate the contrast between
these two warriors there's a lot of
close-ups of the fine armor of damon and
his horse contrasting with the simpler
and scuffed armor of sir kristen
ultimately demon is brought down by his
showboating while damon was more focused
on his ego and the crowd kristen never
took his eyes off the prince victorious
kristen removes his helmet
he's dornish another change from george
r martin's text originally circus is a
stormlander but this series makes him a
dornish son of a steward of lord
dandarian making the southern realm of
dorne even more important the series
with its proximity the triarchies
advances in the stepstones and rainer's
knowledge of nymeria's marriage to
moore's martel of dorne i assume that's
going to come up summoning some inner
authority renera commands cyrax to
ignite the funeral pyres
actress billy alcock rolls that first r
unlike the way daenerys would say it
which makes sense 200 years earlier high
valyrian wouldn't have been as watered
down otto gather is a small council to
discuss with serious succession but we
now see damon watching from the shadows
damon has ambition yes but not for the
throne
he likes the patience for it master of
sneaks this makes us wonder if every
time damon was absent he might have
actually been listening from this hidden
spot because there is snaps
i will not sit here and suffer crows
that come to feast on their corpses yeah
nice word choice there working in an
allusion to a feast for crows otto seals
a message to send to old town presumably
to set some plans to wed his daughter
allison to the king he creepily
instructs her to comfort the king in his
chambers you might wear one of your
mother's dresses
yikes the men of this world viserys toys
with this carved model this depicts
valyria his ancestral home meaning he
must have recreated it from his dreams
with its multiple tears and layers it's
all part of the same base makes me
wonder if these kinds of models could
end up being part of that game of
thrones opening title game board was
that all carved by poor viserys in a sad
lonely train set now to me the most
interesting moment of the episode
damon's speech in the brothel is
intercut with otto reporting it back to
the small council the gods give just as
the gods take away he toasted prince
baylor to the king's son
styling him
the air for a day
now the editing made it seem like we're
gonna cut back to damon for that last
part but we hear otto say it why didn't
they cut to demon for that well notice
how damon doesn't deny sane in the next
scene but he doesn't explicitly admit to
it either the air for a day
did you say it
we must mourn in our own way your grace
george r martin wrote fire and blood as
an in-universe subjective historical
text compiled by an archmaester from
accounts from septon eustis who is
biased because he doesn't approve of
rhaenyra and accounts from a fool named
mushroom who gives his own biased
salacious anecdotes like all of history
it's just based on what people say we
don't really know what the objective
truth was and i bring up this detail
with otto and damon because we don't
know for sure if damon actually said
those precise words of air for a day in
the brothel but he may have said
something similar or he may have said
something even worse maybe he just feels
guilty for being in the brothel at all
and the master of sneaks knows that otto
had him followed and spied on and
nothing he says in this moment is going
to calm his brother also he's got a piss
at his brother now viserys clutches his
sword blackfyre this is a valyrian steel
sword of aegon knows how it's pommel has
a seven-pointed star of the seven damon
says you're weak
viserys
and that council of leeches knows it
council of leeches a fitting term as
leeches were brought up as a possible
remedy with the maesters earlier to
treat viserys's unhealable wound
physical leeches on viserys's wound from
the throne metaphorical leeches on the
king's waning influence and viserys cuts
himself again this time his pinky finger
on the armrest now it's interesting to
note that both of his wounds are on his
left side the side of his body that
demon sits at at the small council table
why do you cut me so deep vazira summons
rhaenyra to the skull of valerian the
black dread and he tells her the idea
that we control the dragons is an
illusion
there are power men should never have
trifled with
when it brought valeria it's doom i love
it viserys is echoing one of my favorite
quotes from game of thrones spoken by
varys
power resides where men believe it
resides
it's a trick
a shadow on the wall viserys says you
are the very best of your mother and i
like how this line plays over a shot of
alison sewing rainier's dress on and
holding her like a mother would as
alison is slowly transitioning from
running her his best friend to her
stepmother damon introduces mazaria to
his dragon correxes i love the breath
from the dragon's mouth blows back
damon's hair it's just a nice practical
interaction between the physical
environment and the vfx just to make
this dragon more than a cgi effect but
viserys dispels the narrative that aegon
conquered westeros purely out of
ambition really aegon was motivated by a
dream and just as danish foresaw the end
of valyria i go on foresaw the end of
the world of men
just to begin with a terrible winter
gusting out of the distant north i love
that when viserys mentions the north of
course that's when we finally cut to the
starks the begrudging rickon stark and
of course a reminder of the stark words
winter is coming now zerus says that
aegon saw in his dream the threat that
we would later identify as the white
walkers and concluded that a targaryen
must sit on the iron throne to unite all
of westeros against this northern threat
aegon call his dream the song of ice and
fire
yes that is aegon's valyrian steel
dagger the same dagger that arya stark
will use to slay the night king and the
one that was given to the assassin to
try to kill bran stark years earlier
this dagger is freaking cursed and of
course it's going to play a very
important role in episodes of this
series as the civil war unfolds but it's
just interesting to learn that aegon was
motivated by the same doom that the
characters and game of thrones will face
however his prophecy was flawed when you
think about it targaryens like danny and
john certainly play an important role in
defeating the white walkers but while
jon was king in the north a targaryen
did not sit on the iron throne when that
happened cersei was sitting on it really
it was arya who dealt the killing blow
and the throne is just gonna end up
getting destroyed while branstar gets
named the king in the aftermath but to
me this flawed thinking is just another
example of the curse of the targaryens
being their own dreams i mean lots of
things brought down the targaryens of
course their own dragons each other
they're diminishing shadows but at the
root of it all i think their paranoia
over their prophecies the mistaken
belief that they must be the heroes of
this story is what drove them mad so now
in this series we're gonna get to see
what happens when mad men convince that
their fire is what will keep us safe
compete to see who can burn everything
down the fastest this episode closes
with a mirror of the succession council
that opened the episode but this time a
supposed correction of that historical
wrong that denied rhaenys her claim now
a woman is named heir breaking
historical precedent a significant way
but since this succession was born out
of the targaryen curse like the lords of
harrenhal the only thing these heirs of
the dragon will inherit will be ashes
you can follow me on tik tok instagram
and twitter at avos follow new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you